Let's take a look at the answer about which intellectual property matched
what is protectable in examples.
For trademark, what is protectable is branding.
Examples are marks and logos and slogans.
For copyright, it's creative, authored works and expressions. Not ideas.
The examples could be software, songs, movies, website content.
For trade secrets, what's protectable is anything. Secrets that you think have economic value.
Examples are non-public technology like the Coke secret recipe,
or your proprietary customer list, or some kind of algorithm or formula
you didn't want to patent.
For contract and non-disclosure agreements, what is protectable is whatever you
and the person who is going to do the deal with you have defined in the contract
and is enforceable in the law.
You could have technology, business information, etc. as examples.
Finally patents. So what's protectable are non-obvious inventions.
Examples are new technology that haven't been previously patented or applied for,
and you have to be first.